I can't this is an expression that is
vilified in our minds beginning at a
young age every time a young child
announces this decision they are
corrected the first adult that hears it
asked them whether or not they have even
tried generally this confrontation will
result in the child giving their task
another attempt until their attention
span moves on to something else the
adult will see this and chuckle to
themselves with knowledge that this is
just a child who is yet to learn the art
of art and virtue of perseverance by the
time this child comes of age however
they will have been told by adults more
times than they could count that there
is no such thing as can't
it is interesting then to think about
how many adults seem to proclaim this
expression in their lives it is because
is it because like many things that
adults tell children they are simply
telling the child a general rule that
the child must follow but can be broken
once one has grown or is it because
these adults are simply repeating what
they were told as children without
thoroughly examining what the phrase I
can't truly suggests if you confronted
an adult that claims they can't do
something with the same question about
whether or not they have tried the
answer will almost always be yes adults
have learned enough to know that is
unreasonable to say they can't until
they have at least tried once therefore
the real question that we should be
asking in responses have you tried
everything have you exhausted every
possible option scenario combination
tool and approach I do not simply refer
to the ones that you knew of at the time
you decided to undertake your task I
mean have you re also researched
possibilities that you had known about
have you determined whether or not there
is another person out there that has
performed the exact same task you are
attempting or at least something similar
have you exhausted this research have
you read every book blog journal
magazine bathroom stall and website if
the answer to any of these questions is
no then go back and try
because if you don't because you don't
truly know if you can do something until
you've tried absolutely everything the
fact of the matter is that rarely if
ever is the answer to all these
questions yes therefore what is it that
people actually mean when they say I
can't a more accurate but more verbose
way of saying it would be I don't care
about or want enough this task or the
resultant benefits of it in order to do
all that is necessary to achieve it I
was told countless numbers of times by
people during my month of marathons that
they couldn't run one marathon let alone
31 straight every now and then when I
had time I would discuss what they'd
said we would jointly conclude that if
something they cared about and depended
on them doing so it would be possible
the most common example I used was if
someone had a gun to your child's head
do you think you could do it then
therefore the phrase I can't denotes a
lack of investment as opposed to a lack
of potential or ability I do not mean to
say that every person I had this
conversation with should have had the
motivation to run marathons it was
something that I decided to do not them
I merely wanted to express to them what
I am expressing here given the right
purpose and enough time you can what
happens if someone has said they can't
we have asked them if they've done
everything and the rare cases happen and
they honestly say yes do we concede that
then they can't nope if everything in
existence has been attempted enough to
determine that it won't work then
congratulations you've been awarded the
honor of being the person who must
invent the method or the tool or
determine the right combination whether
or not you will once again boils down to
how much you care
time they end up being that a person
ends up trying for their entire life but
I suggest removing the phrase I can't
from your lexicon and replacing it with
I can't yet do this so that you don't
risk being on your deathbed saying I
didn't